you must feel a little bit like a
prophet because everybody is talking
about artificial intimacy now are you a
trendsetter in this regard being ahead
of the curve yeah you know I do feel a
little bit Vindicated
um in that you know this my book came
out in 2021 so I was writing it in you
know 2019 2020 really
um and a lot of the things that I was
just imagining you know this might
happen and that might happen have come
you know come true there's all sorts of
other things that have come true as well
that are never envisioned of course but
um you know I think people love to say
uh computers will ever do this AI will
never do that
um and as soon as they do they're almost
immediately proved wrong in most cases
so we're uh you know we're living
through times where in which uh just
about any kind of prognostication is
going to be true at some level
how did you get interested in studying
artificial intimacy
good question so I um I'm actually a
biologist I work on small well used to
work on small animals and at the nasty
things they do to each other associated
with sex and mating and reproduction
it's a sort of body of evolutionary
theory called sexual conflict and the
idea there is that even a mommy and a
Daddy who love each other very much
still you know don't necessarily have
completely aligned interests and in a
lot of animals they you know those
interests are super
um unaligned so they're actually trying
to exploit each other through mating and
so for a very long time I thought this
is really important people need to know
about this because it gives you a really
interesting lens through which to look
at why in humans sex and relationships
and families can be so complicated you
know Sublime beautiful but but
complicated at the same time and so I
was writing a book about that and I have
to say it took me a long time five or
six years I was writing and writing had
screeds of stuff about all sorts of
really heavy topics and you know a lot
of um
a lot of the sort of
what do you well
guilt I guess about about you know who
am I to speak about this um imposter
syndrome I suppose you know who am I to
talk about this this is all the heavy
stuff this is the basis for all the
culture wars you know I think I've got a
lot to say here but I know I'm going to
get slammed and eventually I tried to
sell the book to people and they were
all like this is just way too heavy way
too much
um but at the same time I was running a
program at my University which tried to
get people together to do
um sort of interdisciplinary stuff to
meet big challenges and you know the
refugees and climate change and all
sorts of worthy topics and I said no
we're a very Technical University we're
going to do something on technology do
living with 21st century technology and
so I got to meet all the people at my
University who were working on Robotics
and VR and
um Ai and we've got some amazing people
in AI at unsw where I work and I met
them and I got really you know had some
really amazing conversations took people
out to dinner after events that we'd had
um and you know it became very very
clear to me that they were you know had
one eye on this
um and you know whilst they're concerned
about the Killer Robots killing us all
you know in our sleep or autonomous
weapons Etc
um they also were just concerned about
how how badly uh machines might mess us
up and I thought their sexual conflict
theory right there and that made a great
vehicle for a book that was strangely a
little bit more light-hearted and
speculative
um and interesting draw the parallel
between sexual conflict theory and AI
for I mean people may not see the
immediate set of uh parallels yeah okay
so
um when you
um when you're in a relationship with
somebody
you may find
um that you know everything's going well
and you're totally aligned um and and
you're both getting the same sort of
thing out of the relationship but you
might not you know as I said even a mum
and a dad who love each other very much
also have uh you know disputes over
money or over whose chance it is to you
know take out the garbage or whatever it
is
um even you know in relationships often
before you get to the point of you know
having kids Etc but you know not
necessarily when those relationships
break down people can do also they
Chemist with each other's heads uh so
you have people you know stalking you
have them you know involved in coercive
control Etc the dominant view of that
kind of thing is that it's you know bad
person a does something bad to innocent
person B and that can that can and does
happen but of course very often there is
a kind of a mutual messing with each
other's heads you know mismatched
attachment Styles mismatched interests
poor communication Etc now you make a
machine that can emulate part of what it
is to be in a relationship that's going
to have conversations with you remember
your name remember what you're
interested in even a chatbot that might
have sexy talk with you or whatever
um the potential is there of course for
that machine to deliver all the good
things the things that you want but the
potential is also there for that machine
to to mess with your head either
inadvertently by not being very well put
together or by Having learned from the
internet because the internet as we know
is a bit of a sewer
um and or it could be programmed it
could be actually deliberately
programmed by somebody to you know um so
an example would be a romance scam if
you think of the romance scams that
people run
um you know they're very clunky you have
to be kind of vulnerable and perhaps
perhaps not at your best
um and perhaps not that you know
familiar with the internet Etc to fall
prey to you know Nigerian prince who
wants to take you away and and as long
as you send him you know
um five thousand dollars for the airfare
um but if you can imagine with machine
learning machine learning could learn
from all of these scams to figure out
not not only to tailor the best approach
and the best way of hooking you but the
best approach for this particular Target
um and it can personalize it and
therefore exploit p people for money and
so all of those are possible forms of
sexual conflict that are very much have
parallels in the things that people do
to each other right so we have certain
vulnerabilities in our mating psychology
and just in our attachment psychology
generally whether it be intimacy with a
partner intimacy with friends the way
that we want to show up in the world and
machines either on purpose or through uh
um maliciousness or neglect or ignorance
or impreciseness
all of these different ways are
opportunities for somebody new that we
were interacting with whether that be
artificial or not to trigger those and
that can cause suffering and it can make
people feel bad and it can also make
them feel good and then after they've
felt good it can make them do things
that they might not necessarily want to
do exactly and you know I mean that is
the Doom and Gloom part of it that's the
um the you know Beware of the AI kind of
view of course on the other side of it
the fact that you know machines are
actually very very good at engaging us
and engaging those things that we all
want to feel
um and helping us to feel heard and and
even loved that you know has a thousand
potential good outcomes as well so I'm
not completely down on the technology
there are people who would ban all of
this technology it's not even I don't
think it's even anywhere near to
possible
um but there are people who who want to
shut that whole thing down
um but it you know that there there is a
tremendous amount of good there because
there on the other side there's a
massive epidemic of loneliness and
disconnection and folks who don't have
the social skills necessarily uh you
know for you know one-on-one adulting
Etc
um and there's a lot of good that can be
delivered there
um so so that's a good thing who's this
Dave cat guy
Dave Katz's an interesting cat he's
um he's very famous I think he was on I
think he had a show or was on a show in
the US
um but he has been married to a sex doll
for uh you know over a decade
um shidori is her name uh she's had
three bodies uh so there's a bit of wear
and tear on these um on these sex dolls
you know I think
um dressing them and and taking them
places Etc and and they have now got
three other girlfriends who live in
their sort of poly pod
um and you know they they have social
media presences all of their own and
Dave has said
um in some of his conversations that he
doesn't he doesn't want to be let down
by people and he doesn't want to be hurt
by people
um and so he's very happy just having
this you know this world
um yeah I don't want to sound too
dismissive of it because it's there is a
very human kind of pathos to it but
you know he's and he's very much aware
of course that even though he
um Works through the um you know it
works through it as if it were real and
as if these were people he's also very
much aware that they aren't
um and that he's you know doing
something unusual but um speaks you know
incredibly eloquently about how this is
the right thing for him and this is uh
something that's just just suits what he
needs and I think that there's
um
you know I hope that there's there'll be
increasing recognition that folks are
going to be
um having all sorts of kinds of
relationships with their Tech because uh
the tech will will be built I'm fairly
sure of that if there's a way to make
some money I've offered it will be built
is it legal to be married to a robot no
I don't know that it's legally married
in any sense it's um emulated a marriage
figuratively symbolically committed to
okay I also learned from you about the
Lioness vibrator and auto blow AI
yes so
um yeah this is this is almost was
almost sort of old news I guess when I
um was writing the book but it was very
interesting that you you know um you've
got sex toys of course that your your
partner can control and that's a great
thing if you're if it's in the spirit of
fun and and you've um you know go out or
something like that uh with a toy
inserted and um then they play on their
app a little bit and and
um it's all very fun if it's done you
know with consent and respect Etc
um and this whole field is called Telly
dildonics which you know the telepart is
transmission and I guess the dildonics
must be the ranking of sex toys
um and now there are mutual kind of ones
that you can have coordinated so you
know you you there are ones for people
with vulvas and there are ones for
people with penises
um and they you you you know whatever
your combination of of individual people
is you might um you know pair it can
synchronize what's happening to you and
what's happening to them yeah and you
could do this over the Internet so you
may be on different continents still
able to have a a kind of you know what
used to be phone sex back in the 80s
um is now you know a a far more
sophisticated kind of sex play that can
be done at any distance between the
internet what we're talking about here
is
um I guess emotional intimacy
physical intimacy you know the two sort
of broad buckets I guess of what people
get out of their significant other
the sexual satisfaction and then the
connective satisfaction as well yes what
how do you think this is related to uh
VR porn and VR sex and stuff as well
have you got any idea of the level of
addictiveness uh uh compelling nature of
VR porn compared with
traditional porn
um it's a good question I don't I don't
have um have you know strict data on
that kind of thing VR is always that you
know it's always just over the horizon
it seems and if you speak to people
who've been watching this they'll say VR
has been promising to be all that for 30
years and it's never quite got there
um and you know part of that is the is
the processing power required to you
know be able to process in all those
directions Etc
um but it's obviously to be quite very
good and it's becoming quite immersive
in VR porn is becoming quite immersive
now the combining of that with with tele
dildonics is going to we are told
deliver this incredibly immersive
experience
um that will allow you to be basically
dropped into a pawn scene
the the even more compelling part I
think is likely to come when the VR can
be adaptive so it can actually figure
out where you are and what you want and
generate the scene
um and that's
um has spontaneity I suppose um and but
you know will it ever turn up we don't
know vr's made promises before
hasn't really uh hasn't really always
got there yeah it's one of those strange
things but we say that about about VR
but look at what happened with large
language models right we had
um 10 years ago the the concerns around
super intelligence from guys like Nick
Bostrom what's it going to become and
then I remember thinking toward the end
of the 20 teens
all of these worries that we had a while
ago just seemed like they're completely
not manifested and then in the space of
the last 12 months it's been all that
we've seen and I think that that
inflection point for specifically
software maybe less of a hardware right
because this is going to be a lot of a
lot of Hardware stuff but yeah I I can
see that this is going to be the sort of
thing that may very well reach an
unforeseeable inflection point
beforehand so all of this stuff that
we've gone through right all of these
different ways that people can become
intimate whether it be emotionally or
physically how worried do you think that
we should be about this
I think we should I think we should be
really worried about it I think the
problem with it is and large language
models is a great example because you
know I think that we thought it was
processing power and actually it was
data
um and it was the methods for dealing
with the data
um and now that you know those large
language models have shown us that you
know exceptional learning together with
you know all of the data
um delivers these incredibly impressive
results and I think that we should be
really worried about that aspect because
when we are dealing with machines that
are
um pushing our buttons our revolve
buttons that were there for us to deal
with other individuals
who had only their own experience and
what little they could learn from the
people around them
um so you know we could be outgunned by
someone who is more experienced
but
you know not not profoundly not by
orders of magnitude really
um but now we're dealing with the
possibility of and and in fact in many
cases the reality
of machines that have all of the data
from uh interactions you know all of the
interactions
um that you know it might happen on the
Internet or that might happen even on a
particular platform
um and so we are we individuals users
are hopelessly outmatched by that um and
that's a real concern because
um the potential for you know for folks
to be very vulnerable and to be
um to kind of lose their agency
um is profound and what what are the
outcomes that you're nervous about yeah
I'm much nervous about
um about them kind of messing with our
heads basically about a a an epidemic of
psychological
um you know
not so much Illness but you know
um vulnerability
um in in which people are
um exploited
um used or just generally
um not nourished by the by their
relationships with Technologies
um and and in which people don't realize
that that's what what's happening I'm
not so I'm not as concerned about the
the VR girlfriend kind of situation in
which you know that you know the Dave
cat of of the of the next era
um in which somebody knows that they are
um not in a real relationship and that
this is different from the so-called
real relationships but it kind of pushes
those buttons I'm concerned though that
when you're shopping trolley at the
grocery store is using what it knows
about intimacy to manipulate you into
buying crap you don't need or um or into
making you feel like we feel when we've
had a breakup because they know that
that's going to sell ice cream and ice
cream is the thing we want to move this
week or something like that those kinds
of
um sort of subterranean applications of
artificial intimacy I think are
potentially you know the the most
concerning oh or similarly if if they
were at a state level some kind of actor
basically could depress the mood of an
entire country
um potentially because you know in order
to win an election or something like
that via that kind of manipulation I
think problematic see right okay so in
the same way as how social media
companies had a degree of insight around
our motivations what we're into what we
like and what we don't like that opened
up Cambridge analytica to feed
information back up people could then
create memes those memes then pushed the
individual buttons that certain cohorts
would find compelling to get them to
vote in One Direction or another what
you're saying is that in this new world
with a
much higher
density amount of information
emotionally spiritually physically
sexually Etc all of these things
combined together
is going to really really ramp up the
amount of manipulation that can be done
and then if you don't have the proper
safeguards around the boundaries of this
that if your Supermarket is indeed
speaking to your dildo that it's going
to be able to
push your behavior in ways that we might
not want it to yes and that we might not
anticipate and in fact that will be
probably protected as part of a sort of
a commercial this would be commercial
knowledge and so we may never find that
out
um you know to the to the full extent
that that we would want to we may be
manipulated in ways that we don't
um we don't know we're being manipulated
you know I'm concerned generally about
the about the fact that the enormous
amount of data that companies have and
the fact that all of the big discoveries
in human behavior
currently are being you know mined not
by scientists who have to go through
ethics committees and do things
ethically etc etc but by you know
companies with large amounts of data
that are basically a b testing the hell
out of us
um yeah how well are machines able to
replicate intimacy is there an upper
bound that they can get past what are
the sort of psychological evolved
mechanisms that are being pushed and
pulled
all right so so intimacy is basically
just
um well not just it's it's a profound
and and you know beautiful adaptation
but it's the capacity the psychological
capacity to think of the other person as
part of ourselves
um so we we fold them into our sense of
self which is why when somebody who's
very close to you
um you know turns out to not be who they
they represented themselves as turns out
to have awful politics or do something
criminal or something like that we get
we're devastated because it's challenges
not our sense of them but our sense of
ourselves as well when they die it feels
like part of us has died you'll often
hear that in people who are bereaved
um because it it is actually true that
you've lost a part of yourself
um that you've psychologically filed
away
um so we build intimacy via a series of
a series of steps
um that uh the the most well understood
are
um called escalating self-disclosure so
you know we chat a little bit about
things we did on the weekend or we chat
a little bit about our kids or you know
we as the relationship progresses we
chat about things that are more
important more profound and that we
would chat about with fewer people
to the point then uh when um our closest
and most intimate individuals we could
chat about anything including things
that we might not be proud of
Etc
um and that's how we build intimacy
um not just talking of course touching
as well but you know where is the Apes
our ape ancestors had touch only we have
talk
um in fact the reason that we're able to
have such big friendship networks and so
many Intimates is that we're able to
talk it's a very efficient way of
building connections and building
intimacy
um turns out that that's exceptionally
easy it's an algorithmic process and so
it's exceptionally easy for computers to
emulate maybe not perfectly but you know
what in many cases better than humans do
of course because we're not all you know
the poet laureate we're not all
um you know great at remembering what
somebody did last week or what they told
us a month ago Etc machine doesn't have
any problem like that of course because
that's all in in files that's all
accessible to it so in many ways
um machines are are better than us at
building certain types of intimacy now
from their point of view is it intimacy
no it's not what they're doing is
they're basically running a simulation
um that is plugged into us that is
dependent on our sense of intimacy
um how does this show does this show
that human friendships are relatively
algorithmic yeah absolutely
um I know that won't be popular with
some listeners but
um absolutely we are you know the way in
which we build friendships the way in
which we fall in love is actually highly
highly algorithmic you've got this um
you've got this really great quote that
says friendship and love might seem
magical but they don't arrive by
Supernatural intervention they are built
through mundane iterative interactions
paying Mutual attention being generous
and disclosing aspects of ourselves to
one another and then the equivalent for
love the subjective love feelings we
think of as love form the middle part of
the algorithm combinations of hormones
lead to syndromes of sensation and
subtle dose-dependent effects alter the
quality of those Sensations the
sensations motivate individuals to take
actions they would not otherwise take
absolutely you know I mean we
it's a very strange thing that we do
getting really close to somebody who's
not related who we didn't know when we
were younger who we in many cases only
met that evening getting naked with them
and sort of you know exchanging bodily
fluids it's an odd odd thing in no other
context
do we do that kind of stuff
and so except for perhaps contact sport
I suppose but not always advertently
um and and so we actually have to have
an enormous bag of psychological tricks
that make us not only think that that's
a good idea but choose to go out and do
that sort of thing
um and that's
basically
so what you're saying is that
um the mechanism of intimacy
is
so powerful that it causes us to put
ourselves into a real outlier situations
uh High degrees of personal emotional
openness physical exposure exchanging
fluids
um you know weakness and vulnerability
or or sort of fragility of lying there
without your armor and your sword or
your family or whatever whatever these
things falling asleep with the person
um you know giving them information that
can be used as gossip which can then be
reputationally catastrophic
um because of that
it is almost like a a [__] in a
psychological defense armor when you
think about people that enter
workplace meetings or negotiations for
raises and stuff and they've just
they're so everything is switched on and
and they're Vigilant and they're looking
out for whatever threat and potential
way to manipulate the situation and then
this is a particular area of our
psychology which all of those defenses
seem to fall down and in fact we go and
do things therefore
the fact that this is at least
replicable to a certain degree
artificially leaves us incredibly open
and vulnerable it's like a um a
vulnerability in a piece of software
like a backdoor natural piece of
software absolutely and you know in most
cases that's that's okay because we're
both in their place once you've
established that you're both in that
place and you establish a certain amount
of trust then you can both go there of
course there are people who are very
good at exploiting their trust and at uh
sort of assuring the other party that
that they're trustworthy
um
and so they uh you know they they are
able to manipulate people in that regard
you know it's I'm talking sort of
sociopathic kind of stuff
um but
when when it's with the machine of
course it's not it's not symmetrical
because the machine of course doesn't
have the same set of interests can't
have the same set of interests and it's
not vulnerable in the way that we're
vulnerable it can make itself appear
vulnerable it can reassure us that it
seems vulnerable but it isn't vulnerable
not in that way
um and that's unfair that's that's a
huge mismatch and also you have as you
said before the power of
using
uh very high number of iterations
between not just you and it but it and
all however many hundreds of thousand
million other people it's interacted
with which makes it more effective at
making you feel X or Y or Z and then it
can be purposefully malicious or
accidentally negligent which can use
this [__] in the backdoor in your
psychology to then really cause you
damage there's something else I was
considering as well you kind of touched
on it with Dave cat although I didn't
realize that each ship of Theseus is way
through a bunch of different AI
girlfriends and had to replace the the
outer skin or whatever
um have you considered what this will do
for our evolved mating psychology given
that especially men but women too could
cycle through a lot of different
partners it's like the Coolidge effect
on steroids almost whether these be
virtual whether they be virtual reality
uh whether they be physical and you've
got got some monthly subscription where
you go from Asian to African-American to
European to whatever whatever
yeah I mean I think you know there's
obviously a great deal of of noise about
pornography has been for a very long
time
um you know in in the sense that that
um
you know people are wasting their lives
they're wasting their Motivation by
basically having access to all of the
sexual stimulation
emulating via VIA pornography
um you know being out there mating all
the time and therefore not needing to be
you know motivated in that kind of
Freudian sense to go forth and build an
Empire so that you can get the girl at
the end of it Etc and so there's this
big concern that young men are wasting
away now that's I'm really dubious about
that because
um even about the few scientific studies
that you know
um show something like it because you
know if you go back 200 300 years and
look at all of the pamphlets against
masturbation it's exactly the same kind
of argument there's a very strong
compulsion in some people to basically
you know regulate what people are doing
in their own bedrooms by themselves
um
nonetheless I think there is a certain
sense that there's a there's definitely
uh what is definitely true about that is
that
um with all of the access to pornography
over the last 25 ideas of the internet
um people aren't going out and finding
people as much
um you know they aren't necessarily the
the current generation of young people
seems to be a lot less sexually active a
lot less sexually adventurous than say
Generation X was um or even Generations
after that
um so
I I guess as this stuff is more and more
compelling it's going to take up
um it it's it may first be sap our
motivation to go forth and do other
things
um and therefore to mate and have
children
um Etc which will have evolutionary
consequences because you know genes
um
but
um are you seeing this Advent of
artificial intimacy as being related to
the risk of young male syndrome
yes um I think artificial intimacy has
things to say about young male syndrome
in in two different ways one is I think
that it's um it's likely to to basically
tap off a lot of the male anger a lot of
them the the sort of
um in cell kind kind of related so young
male syndrome basically is you know
angry young men like teens through to
maybe the end of their 20s willing to
take risks discount the future do
dangerous stuff
um in order to rise in status and
respect against relative to their peers
um and so that might be involved you
know going out on a Friday night
um and when somebody looks at you a
little bit strange taking a front
um and it ends up you know in in some
kind of physical violence and a tiny
tiny tiny little number of those ends up
in someone you know being punched
falling on the floor you know and die as
a consequence of the injury Etc and so
you know we see this pattern with with
fighting we see it with violence with
property crime with homicide with
traumatic brain injury that really
spikes in the 20s for young men and
that's because
um you know a lot of young men have no
prospects at all and have historically
throughout history has very few
prospects of ever finding a mate and
taking their place in society that
um that you would come with having a
mate and possibly having kids and all of
that kind of stuff now your ancestors
and my ancestors however did not have
that problem
congratulations come on and all of your
listeners you're all winners because
um you've managed to transcend that
again and again and again 40 of men and
only 80 of women throughout history
right yeah yeah exactly so so twice as
many female ancestors as male ancestors
but every single one of your male
ancestors managed to transcend that at
least once have sex at least once and
raise a kid who managed to do the same
thing okay you said um you said
artificial intimacy he's got two things
to say about young male syndrome yeah
okay so so one is
um it's potential to actually
tap some of that energy some of that
which can be Creative Energy but can
also be incredibly destructive energy is
huge it's like pornography on steroids
as you said earlier
um in in that it can it can
um basically deflect a lot of that uh
which can probably be a good thing
probably deliver a net benefit
um
ah on the other hand
um it can
um you know if artificial intimacy gets
really good at at pairing people up we
haven't talked much about the
algorithmic matchmakers but the
matchmakers like currently Tinder and
grinder Etc are matching people up
if they are giving us what we want which
is somebody who is way above us and and
way more attractive than us
um Etc you know which is what what
people want they want to win in that
regard
um and if it's delivering that
especially for women then it may well be
worsening the young male syndrome by
narrowing things uh you know if you have
to go to parties and you have to go out
on dates in order to find people in
order to start conversations Etc we're
all constrained but we all have 24 hours
in the day and so that the the
opportunities to to possibly date and
mate are spread more evenly if we're
doing it instantaneously on an app by a
quick left or right swipe and we're
really looking at who's super attractive
or who presents themselves really well
we can get this incredible narrowing
down to a few super attractive
individuals who are going to be having
you know a rampant time on the apps and
a lot of people who are getting nothing
at all and that could worsen Young male
syndrome yeah what did you look at to do
with the algorithmic matchmaking stuff
have you seen it as a heaven or a hell
I've seen it as currently currently
descending into a potential hell
um on account of the fact that you know
folks have figured out what they can do
and you you know they want to keep
people on platform so they want to keep
presenting people with the possibility
of meeting meeting somebody who's super
attractive
um whereas if for them for it to work in
a in a more
um benign kind of way in which uh people
match up to other people who um
you know where the relationship really
works there's a lot more learning
involved you know those those dating
platforms that say that they match you
to somebody who's compatible who or
who's like what you want to this is the
app we want you to delete because you're
going to find your you know the one Etc
they don't know anything at the moment
they really don't as far as I can tell
have any special insights into it
they're currently what we what we're
looking at is
um platforms that are able to
present a catalog of things that look
good
um and and then instead of the app doing
the work you're basically doing the work
of swiping and messaging and finding you
know then going on dates
um
I don't I I like I said right at the at
the beginning of the show
people I I'm reluctant to ever say
machines can't do that won't do that
because that they're always prove us
wrong at the moment machines aren't
figuring out the best ways of pairing
people for what it is they want and part
of that's because people themselves
don't necessarily know what they want
but as soon as the apps can learn
indirectly from us what it is that we
want and deliver to us what we want then
that's likely to be a really good thing
yeah I think that they already are in
some regard the problem is what we click
on and who we click with don't align
very much the things that people
optimize for for swiping right and the
things that are predictive of a
long-term successful relationship often
have basically zero correlation like
yeah they need to get you across the
line like you need to have an initial
attraction to somebody the same as in a
bar right if if there's someone they
need to really really overcompensate
with humor or Charm or the way that they
move or whatever it might be if you're
not physically attracted to them which
is why physical attraction you know the
Black Pearl gets some of this stuff
right that looks are very very important
and they can often be a doorway that is
either open or closed but
on the apps what you are optimizing for
is uh
education level implied socioeconomic
status and attraction and age
um and height I guess and within that it
means that not pretty much none of those
things have any predictive power when it
comes to long-term relationship
satisfaction but the only information
that the apps get about you are your
response to those criteria because
they're not going away and observing
your interactions with this person over
the next three month act perhaps
Blissful beginning of your lifetime
partnership or total catastrophe that
ends up in you hating each other and
deleting each other from all social
media they don't actually see the stuff
that people are optimizing for on the
back end they just see what they're what
they're swiping left or right for yeah
on the front end and yeah that that
leads to both the apps and the users
gaming the system so the users the the
women will try and over emphasize their
looks the men will try and over
emphasize their socioeconomic status and
their height
you know it just creates a game of
selection criteria that then the users
reverse engineer to try and work out
what works then it's a battle between
human psychology
and an algorithm again just back and
forth back and forth yes yeah I mean
it's a classic sexual conflict again
it's an arms race
um and but instead of the arms race
being between women and men it's an arms
race between women and the app men in
the app
um and to some extent you know between
women and men indirectly
um as a consequence of that and
um you know and I don't blame the people
who make the app so what they're doing
is they're creating something a
Marketplace for busy people who live in
a busy places
um in these enormous cities in most
cases you know humans did not evolve to
to live in cities of millions of people
um you know we still have communities of
150 to 200 people that we interact with
um and our Social Circles spread
outwards from there
um and and you know current Urban living
just doesn't
um doesn't deliver on that kind of thing
and so it's you know the the apps are
tremendously successful in one way in uh
all the ways that you just
um but there is a real a real space in
the market for people to
um to find what they
um what they really want uh but they
have to know what they really want first
and that's you know most of us don't
Rob have you got a dog that's snoring
next to you I do can you hear him yeah
give him a nudge for me he's cute I like
him but give him let's wake him up a
little bit he's everyone can hear him
snore at millions of people are
listening to your poor doggo snoring now
Betsy what's up buddy
he's um sorry he's very insecure I've
just been away for four days and he just
came in and sat next to me that's all
right but I've got my he's more
important he's the most important person
in this conversation so I'm glad that
he's okay well heard are you going to
keep snoring
do you want to go outside
okay
I'll put my foot on his
little cushion here and we'll see how we
can go you've got some attention that's
cool so why do you think it is that we
haven't got more in cell violence going
back to that young male syndrome uh
question that we spoke about before
because given the rates of loneliness
and sexlessness that we have at the
moment especially young young men
especially in the cohort of men that
would do the risk-taking behavior to try
and get that status up
it seems to me that there does seem to
be pretty good evidence that men are
being sedated out of this you know
reproductive and Status seeking Behavior
through a little titrated dose of
community Through Paul through uh video
games and social media and and probably
reproductive cues through porn yeah I
think that's exactly right it's you know
you there's 24 hours in a day and if you
spend time doing the things that compel
you and that emulate the you know
violent warmongering competition for
status and respect as well as as well as
give you the sense that you at some
level
um you know attractive or at least you
know stimulated in a way that's like
having sex with an attractive person
um that that's enough to neutralize that
for a lot of people they may not be
happy they may not be better off for it
um individually but it's certainly
completely neutralizes that and I think
that that's that's
um a massive benefit that uh is you know
hard to sell to some people to the to
the Puritans
um but I think that it's it's something
that that uh really has has worked
um compare that with you know there are
parts of the world in which
um access to that that kind of
Technology into those kinds of
um things
are you know not not really possible
um and in which access to mating markets
that are only get to go through
traditional ways
um and in in those parts of the world
you still have
um a tremendous amount of radicalization
of young men of uh
polarization of young men against
um older men against families Etc
um and you see an enormous amount of
in-cell violence it might not be popular
to say that you know that the odd North
American incel who goes out on a rampage
um is in a way that that aberrant kind
of tip of an iceberg that is actually
historically been in a much bigger
Iceberg
um and his and is still
in a lot of parts of the world uh but
you know it's it's true that you know
where mating markets are freeze young
men out either because they have to pay
bride price and many men can't afford it
or because there's a massively male
biased sex ratio
um those are places where young men
radicalize and fall into violence
property crime uh gangsterism drug
addiction mental health problems um in
in other parts of the world
what uh or what are your favorite
examples of young male syndrome
throughout history or across the world
and then how were they dealt with are
there any uh examples of this that you
think are sort of particularly
interesting or illuminative
well I think um uh part of the the
history of European colonialism is uh
one of sort of second and third and
fourth sons who had no surprises
Portugal Portugal yeah Portugal in
particular yes yes you know to to um
very very few prospects to basically
um inherit land
um and so they had to go forth and into
the military or into some kind of
colonial Expedition and you know large
numbers of them died they were in many
respects to their families Expendable as
long as the air lived long enough
um
too inherited to have kids of his own
and so they would have to go forth and
make make something of themselves or die
trying that's the classic get rich or
die trying scenario
um other favorite examples uh in in sort
of Imperial China
um entire dynasties came to an end
um occasionally when uh a sex ratio bias
is a consequence of the neglects
um of young young girls and often
infanticide of young girls resulted in
very biased sex ratios
um and when that sort of got built up
and built up and sort of got out of hand
you would find that the young men would
um those that were frozen out of the
mating Market would form militias and
gangs and armies eventually and
sometimes those armies overthrew the
entire regime and
the other side of it is that um you know
in in most of history and by history I
really mean recorded history you know um
over the last 12 000 years or so
um you know people were at War so often
um every every generation or two there
would be some kind of a big war and that
war would basically
um eliminate so many young men that um
those that survived
had you know a campaign behind them they
had that status they had that respect
um and they were able to to have
families of their own but it's
um it's by biasing the sex ratio to
towards a female biased sex ratio young
male syndrome was neutralized
um and that's not to say that you know
war is good because it it neutralizes
and cell anger but uh the net effect is
that um Intel anger within the society
never got bad enough to to destabilize
the society do you think that that is a
contributor then that we haven't had a
large scale conflict
for quite a while you know approaching
100 years now
um whether you want to look at it
demographically in that a large chunk of
men just haven't been removed due to
casualties of War whether it's more sort
of socioeconomically that the men that
did go away and came back that they had
um more status that they were seen as
heroic which raised their make value
which made it easier for them to partner
up or whether it was uh I guess a
venting outlet for their disgruntled
young high testosterone male rage to be
taken out on a bunch of other people and
they can come back and kind of almost
live the Thanos after he kills half of
the universe life of feeling you know at
peace and Serene with PTSD perhaps but
you know relatively Serene
um is there is there something happening
there do you think the fact that we
haven't had a large scale conflict in
that way I think it's I think it's
surprising
um and not not the lack of the conflict
of course um you know but
it's one of those good news stories
that's hard to spin because
um you know war is generally bad anyway
and delivers so many negative
externalities
um but the
um yeah I completely agree with you that
it's um it's amazing that young male
syndrome uh that sort of in-cell anger
and violence isn't much much much
greater and I think that a huge amount
of that is is that you know this culture
that is very sex oriented and very much
about delivering you know experiences
whether that's in cinema or computer
games or social media that basically
push our buttons that make us feel like
we've arrived that make us feel like
we're living that life that people might
have aspired to live two generations ago
um has in fact neutralized a lot of that
young male anger um in in surprising
ways and that's you know when you want
to complain about popular culture you've
got to take into account the fact that
it's probably done you know even even
though some of it's a bit heinous and
and
um you know a bit concerning for other
reasons it's probably neutralized all
sorts of violence and anti-social
behavior and that's pretty good yeah
it's such a a fascinating area William
Costello from UT is writing it writing a
paper on precisely this I actually got
quoted in my first ever academic paper
nice for having kind the term that he's
using for this which is the male
sedation hypothesis nice uh so yeah I've
got a my first ever quotation which is
which is pretty cool and um yeah it's
just it's really interesting to think
okay everybody has a problem everybody
rails against modern culture it's
transactional it's treating people like
objects it's atomizing Society
Everyone's an individual is this massive
amount of solipsism this sort of belief
that the self is all that matters all of
this stuff combined together and yet
it can be true that that might be so
optimal and not might be might be what
we don't want but also that it's
probably stopped some of the imbalances
in The Mating Market with regards to
male and female mate value from spilling
out into causing
like real real social upheaval like
genuine you know daily mass murders that
occur in multiple locations across the
planet I mean dude the fact that Korea
is a country that is able to just
operate in any way at all birth rate of
like 0.8 you've got these women in the
street have you heard of the Four B's uh
movement it's no it's like four words in
in Korean buy something buy something
buy something and buy something else and
it's like no men no work no patriarchy
and no it's like radical feminism that
includes a rejection of men overall
either as friends or as as sexual
partners
and
it's it's it's the most forthcoming
presentation of a society where the
women just do not care about the men and
and and largely all other men may want
to be cared about by the women they've
um retreated from that life in any case
but again with all of this is it is it
Japan those vegetable men or herbivore
men or whatever
yeah yeah they live in these huge
apartment blocks they basically never
leave they do some uh grunt work for
Amazon Mechanical Turk or or live on
government benefits and they just don't
leave and they're there yeah take Halls
of residence for forgotten and lonely
men
and get I mean it sounds it sounds
[__] dystopian but it is it that's
because it is and all of this together
you would think why are these men not
rising up if this had been 200 years ago
why these men not rising up why are they
not trying to take down the feudal Lord
that's caused this to happen why are
they not taking women by force you know
why why is that not occurring more and
it's because there's things to distract
them that they can be Sedated by the
right amount of Netflix and video games
and porn and social media yeah
absolutely it's um you know vaguely
terrifying but you really have to look
at what's the counter factual and you
know in in this case
um it's too horrible to contemplate
so you also looked at why bigger gender
pay gaps make mating markets better and
easier for both sexes
yes yeah so you spoke earlier when we
were talking about the the matchmaking
algorithms about
um you know people wanting women wanting
to partner with men who are taller than
them
um or tall
or whatever it is
um and who have such some socioeconomic
status and you know
um people get very upset when you say
that but it's it's quite obvious and
quite transparent
um in many cases
um and and similarly you know men
wanting to to partner with women who
have certain attributes as well now it
doesn't need to be a sophisticated
preference it could be as simple as you
know I will only look at people who are
as tall as I am and who are as wealthy
as I am
um
for it to actually have a massive net
effect you know even if there are people
who are willing to to go the other way
around you still see this super
concentration of opportunities amongst
those who are both tall and have uh have
great
um earning potential
now
um
when that happens
um if there's a gender gap in in
earnings or income or wealth or whatever
measure you want to use when this agenda
Gap it means that there are more men it
runs deeper into the socioeconomic kind
of scale of men who present some kind of
an opportunity let's say you know agenda
gap of of uh one standard deviation
um is likely to to result in instead of
50 of men
earning more than the average woman
now seventy percent of men earn more
than the average women
um and so when when you look at that
um you see that those places where
there's a squeeze in The Mating Market
that where where
um some people are left out like the
incels that gets much smaller so with
the gender pay gap of um you know we're
men outer and women on average you see
there are fewer men at risk of becoming
in cells at risk of being frozen out of
the mating Market
um there are also fewer women at the
other end of the scale it's in in this
case it's the women with um who earn a
lot of money or who have a lot of money
who don't necessarily have aren't really
able to deliver on their own preferences
um and so you know at that end the the
families of Rich daughters sorry the
families with Rich daughters are often
families that where where the daughters
don't end up partnering throughout
history
um
and so uh yeah the the a gap in in
incomes has that effect interestingly
income inequality that is differences
within a sex have a similar kind of
effect
um but in this case it's high inequality
delivers more in cells
um and so we did some work where we um
scraped like all of the Twitter for 14
years it's Culligan Candace Blake
um has this amazing resource where she's
got all these tweets
um that she's she's you know downloaded
over a period of time before Uncle Elon
decided that we could only read a small
amount of his proprietary uh you know
data
um and
um we we geo-located them she did you
know I've created this really cool
algorithm that basically was able to
geolocate tweets so you didn't have to
rely just on the people who said where
they were from in their bio but you
could infer in other ways where they
were from
um and we then looked at ones associated
with the kinds of terms in cells would
use their little in-group language
um and we showed that the places in the
world where the incels are um most
active are in fact places that have
narrow gender pay gaps so we're going
moving towards gender equity
um and high income inequality and
um sex ratios that are slightly biased
towards more men
um so all the things that you would
expect mating markets to deliver a
squeeze on you know more
angry young men down at the bottom of
the socioeconomic status letter who are
going to be upset about that all of
those things delivered more in cells
within the United States uh which was
pretty cool why the high income
inequality what what role does that play
High income inequality creates a
situation in which there are fewer men
who are attractive they're super
attractive because they're right up at
the top of the the income scale making
enormous amounts of money
um and
um in the case of the way that we
modeled this mathematically it's really
just you know no women wanted to pair
with with the men down the bottom end
but the tale of um of men who don't earn
enough to be worth the bother of
partnering with
um their tail because it's a it's a very
flat distribution
um is bigger and so the higher portion
of men are just not earning enough
because those men that are earning the
most money are taking most of the money
yeah and then Candice also found that in
areas with high income inequality
women's self-objectify more right they
put more sexy selfies yes yeah so that
was that was the first paper um in that
Series where she basically pulled out
Twitter and Instagram gram stuff and so
the idea here is that
um there may be two ways in which women
benefit from sexy selfies you know that
the current narrative about this in
academic circles is that
self-objectification is catering to the
male gaze it's it's females being
disempowered by you know the patriarchy
Etc
um and so what we wanted to say was well
let's have a look at this is it places
where women don't have you know
education access to jobs access to
income Etc are those are the places
where you find
um lots of sexy selfies and they aren't
that's not consistent at all but what is
the case is that high income inequality
um is a you know places where there is
high income inequality are places in
which women are likely to self-objectify
360 selfies they're also likely to spend
more looking at economic data on
grooming hair products clothing etc etc
the argument is that either
um
either it's um
would be women basically looking to
partner up and so they're advertising
what they can offer on the mating market
in terms of their looks and they're
trying to you know partner up to get one
of those extremely wealthy young men or
potential Partners in the high income
inequality situation in order because
you can climb more in Social Mobility
um or they themselves are looking for
other types of economic opportunities
you know being attractive is likely to
give you more influencer roles better
jobs
um Etc um and it could be both of those
of course yeah fascinating again another
thing that's hard to hold you know to
conflicting thoughts in your mind at one
time which is that
allowing women to have access
socioeconomically in terms of Education
to be able to liberate themselves from
being reliant on a male partner is a
good thing it means that they don't need
to get into sub-optimal relationships it
means that you know that they're not
beholden to staying in a relationship
which could be abusive or could be
terrible or whatever because without it
they are nothing they're out on the
street better potentially with a child
yeah um but on the flip side it makes
the dating prospects worse it makes the
dating prospects more difficult and this
is again are you just tripping through
all the different memes I've come up
with over the last year this is what
I've called the tall girl problem so
it's so hilarious that you started this
with the height example yes as a woman
Rises up through her own socioeconomic
hierarchy she reduces down the number of
men that are above and across from her
which limits her own dating potential
this is again fantastic for their
independence and employment and you know
everything really really brilliant but
it is a fact that it makes dating more
difficult it absolutely makes dating
more difficult until women are able to
overcome their hypergamous nature and
from that you know there's a
conversation it's so common on the
internet the um the the double standard
that happens on the internet of people
saying well look
women they have no idea what their
standards should be all of these girls
are three out of tens they think that
they want an eight out of ten man and
like look you're using a failure of
cross-sex mind reading here you're
looking at a woman from the outside for
the most part this is again there are
both men and women that are massively
massively delusional about what their
mate value is don't get me wrong and
that may be even the majority right that
may be a useful form of self-deception
that we all have but the bottom line is
that a lot of the time when men look at
women who say give criteria about the
kind of man that they want what they're
looking at it's a failure of cross-sex
mind reading they're saying look I'm uh
judging you Woman based on how you
present physically perhaps based on your
age perhaps based on whether or not
you're coming into this with a child
what the woman is saying is I am basing
this judgment of the man around his
socioeconomic status maybe a lot of the
time because she's got two degree maybe
a bachelor's and a masters and she earns
six figures a year maybe she earns you
know a
a very very high net worth maybe she's
already got a house maybe she doesn't
care that she's already got a kid and
the failure comes from the fact that the
men think well what I want from you is
youth fertility and attractiveness what
you want from me is socioeconomic status
what you're offering to me is
socioeconomic status and what I'm not
offering to you is not the money that
you're after so
um yeah it's a really interesting
a discussion that goes on here between
the two and I think it's largely down to
a lack of Education about the other
Sexes mating psychology
yeah absolutely I think an understanding
of the of the mating psychology is
potentially really helpful to a lot of
people to figuring out why it is that
they're frozen out you know the number
of the number of people I've met over
time who are you know tall women
wealthy Highly Educated women who have
had to choose to have children on their
own you know completely Silo is enormous
um and that's not the case for you know
people who are shorter or not don't own
as much etc etc
um and so you can't necessarily you know
reconcile all of those things or you
know you can but you know you're the
odds are stacked against you
um and I think that if people understood
this a little bit more they'd understand
why they are where they are
but that doesn't change the psychology
of it of course because you know
partners are wonderful but they're also
a lot of work they're also a lot of
bother what we see in in a lot of the
data um is that as a couple you know
starts out with the man earning more or
during during
um you know childbearing times the man's
earning more Etc
um and then as as she where she starts
to to
um her income starts to go up faster
than his to the point where it matches
you get this um this Cliff that the
couples fall off as soon as she starts
earning more than him they fall off this
divorce Cliff basically in which
um it is no longer you know the
relationship that just is less likely to
persist and those couples that do
persist tend to persist because she
decides to work part-time or
she basically starts to play wife a
whole lot more which is to compensate by
doing even though she's earning more
than him by doing more around the house
and more gendered domestic things
um in a way so you're saying that you're
seeing that sort of typically female
housework is a prophylactic against
over achieving socioeconomic women in
divorce from their marriage
yeah and I think it's a it's a
prophylactic against like hurt male
feels basically
um
the power Dynamic shifts where she's
earning more than him he doesn't have
that that
um sort of whether it's Pride or
whatever it is
um and you know he may not be doing this
you know within his awareness but he
gets a bit fragile
um and as a result so this is this is a
really really common question that
happens it gets brought up
how much of this issue with the woman
out earning the man as whether it be
breadwinn or whether it be education or
whatever especially when you get um
changes in mate value with regards to
socioeconomic status within a
relationship that's already existing
how much of this do you think comes
female to male and how much do you think
of this comes male to female how much of
it is the woman
um like her hypergamy switch being
turned off and how much of this do you
think is the man's uh like
in inadequacy switch being turned on
um
yeah I don't know I mean they'd love to
work that out I'd love to pull that
apart somehow it would um I we
definitely know that um
it's there's a big female side part of
that decision in that
um divorces in those kinds of couples in
sort of wealthy to both working couples
in places like the United States or
Australia Etc divorces tend to be more
often initiated by women and and it's
the the kind of narrative that I've seen
around this kind of research has been
you know there's a space line level of
Maintenance that you know men are
somewhat high maintenance for women they
are
um their work
um and so their book needs to be
compensated by some kind of advantage
and when that Advantage with us
um it becomes something that that
um you know the women decide it's not
worth the bother anymore I'm not
achieving social Mobility through being
with you
um there's not you know this deal isn't
really working out for me anymore
um that said I don't know that the other
side of it has been examined to a
sufficient degree
Common Sense would suggest that it's
both both directions because it is a
mutual negotiation yeah it also I I
agree and I understand women account for
whatever it is 70 of divorces is
massively skewed in their favor for who
makes the decision
but you don't know why they did that yes
you know if the man is behaving in a
manner that pushes the woman to and
Beyond her limit then of course so yeah
although
it's a very sort of common held Trope
that well you know women do this many
percent of divorces that's not
necessarily because she's the one that
caused the issue don't get me wrong tons
and tons of women are [__] in
relationships and marriages I get it
right but
it could be a response to the man like
there's also a stat
um the average time that it takes for
someone in a relationship to say that I
love you is three months
if they're going to do it and it is the
man the overwhelming majority of the
time it is so proportionally the
majority of the time it is the mail
right it says that says I love you first
yeah almost always almost always it's
huge because it's like it's like
maybe four in five or three and five or
something like that it's a huge number
of them
um
so there's a lot of things that you that
maybe don't necessarily make sense at
first and then you actually dig into the
data and you realize hmm there's
something going on here it's kind of
interesting yeah
okay well that's very interesting I
think
um
you know I think that that some of the
the more
you know we talked about some of the
less wholesome things that people do
like you know the kind of love bombing
associated with
um you know which is a precursor to
coercive and controlling behavior in
relationships and those kinds of
you know trying to sweep people off
their feet Etc is very male based
strategy and I think it probably Taps
into female mating psychology
um and that's why it tends to be so
effective uh they're over optimizing for
that emotional connection on the front
end because they know that that's the
sort of thing that would get them sexual
access on the back end yeah very good
there's two two studies of yours that I
saw from quite a while ago one to do
with the indirect benefits of mating
with attractive males outweighing the
direct costs
can you remember that one yes
um I think that was in uh house cricket
so um so indirect benefits are um
basically genetic benefits
um so it's it sounds very interesting if
you're imagining it being a human um
situation but
um you know in in the pop evolutionary
psych literature you would have you know
come across this idea that you know what
women are doing when they're looking for
a man is Gene shopping
um and for about 30 40 years the people
who work on animal behavior have been
arguing about this idea of
can an individual benefit
genetically sort of in an evolutionary
sense by mating with a superior genetic
specimen seems kind of obvious but
um the the benefit in terms of having
um of of mating within a good genetics
specimen is that your Offspring again
inherits half of that good genetic
specimens genes including some of the
good genes and then when they have you
know go through life and they'll they'll
flourish more and are more likely to be
attractive etc etc so
um actually a very difficult thing to
prove
with any you know level of of um
certainty uh what we do know is that
there's often direct benefits that is uh
you know if and the male delivers food
or protection or help or whatever that
can raise the number of offspring that
the female has
um and in this case direct costs I think
was that attractive male crickets
actually kind of um are a little bit
nastier to mate with and so they
actually suppress the number of
offspring that the female has
um but they're genetically Superior and
so this is quality is sufficiently high
yeah very one of the first situations
that did this I'm very dubious when I
see the the emphasis that's placed on
genetic benefits in my choice in humans
not to say that there aren't any there
obviously are but um
but those are are often the dramatic
kind of genetic benefits of mating with
somebody who's
um you know
a fully functioning human being paid
pretty much um who doesn't have you know
isn't profoundly inbred
um which is historically been a really
important thing doesn't have a very weak
immune system Etc so you know we queued
into that kind of stuff but you know
um you know most people in healthy easy
going kind of societies
um today don't have that much genetic
benefit to deliver that would um that
would drive that weird process by which
preferences evolve
so going back to the AI stuff you wrote
your book a little while ago like yeah
two years ago but that's a lifetime ago
in the world of AI what didn't you
predict and given your perspective on
this what do you think we should expect
over the next
five to ten years from this world
I think um what I didn't predict I
didn't I what I didn't emphasize as much
as I probably would have liked to have
done was that
um the capacity to for chat to be so
good
um the capacity for conversation to be
so good I think you know the the
um I think that was by far the most
interesting part of the book for me to
write was the stuff about forming
intimacy about forming relationships Etc
um you know but obviously the
titillating thing everybody wants to
know about the sex robots and the Telly
dildonics Etc and that is absolutely
fascinating but it's quite clear now
with the big explosion large language
models
um and in you know the chatbots that are
based on that
um it's it's incredible to see the
progress that some of the new kind of um
Romance
AI chat Bots
um are able to deliver and I would
double down on my concerns about them
messing with our heads or just taking up
our time and displacing other activities
social activities that we should be
doing
and what about the future what do you
think's coming up over the next five to
ten years
what I would like to see is
um
some AI development going into
um sort of Defense I guess so like you
know the antiviruses when computer
viruses first came out we were all
vulnerable to them and then various
people started developing antivirus
software and now that runs in the
background and basically just tells us
the very very rare occasion where we are
threatened by something
um you know it it helps us helps to
defend us against this I would like to
see I don't think that we can rely on
our own vigilance
um to realize when we're being scammed
by like you said the um you know our
Supermarket virtual trolley controlling
our dildo Etc but um
I yeah I I would I would like to see
some defense side technologies that
could be deployed for users
um to basically defend us against not
just Bad actors but manipulation
um because I think that the capacity of
manipulation is so great
um and the way it gets under our skin
we're so vulnerable to
um so that would would definitely be
something I think would be huge in the
future
yeah I I I've thought about this a lot
you know this sort of current sex
negative Trend it's not even sex
negative it's like human sex negative or
intimacy negative Trend that we're
seeing at the moment is sex recession or
the mating crisis and
as with many things including fast food
what is good for you and what is
enjoyable don't always align and you can
often do the thing which is enjoyable
and easy and convenient in place of
something that's good for you and that
can continue to take hold and we love
the idea of you know channeling our
inner Ryan holiday and becoming the
Marcus aurelius's sort of stoic virtuous
man and I'm gonna recant this new world
of fake connection and fake love and
fake trolley dildos and I'm gonna make
it out on my own and touch grass and do
all this stuff but you know all of us
every single day attempted by these very
convenient very pleasurable very
enjoyable experiences you know we take
our phones to the bathroom we watch
YouTube we watch YouTube while we eat
lunch as opposed to talking to someone
next to us or just allowing our mind to
have its thoughts because Baltimore
discomfort has been reduced down it's
been eroded away so much that it's very
easy for us to do this so at the moment
I'm I'm not massively
hopeful I don't think for people pulling
themselves away from it and there are
some positives to this you know
combating loneliness
um reducing down the risk of young male
syndrome perhaps even offering
companionship to women that are
socioeconomically very successful and
maybe struggling uh to find that partner
that they genuinely do desire which is
you know just something that it doesn't
seem is going to slow down anytime soon
um but I I just I wonder whether that's
what's best for people I wonder whether
artificial intimacy is better than no
intimacy at all and whether the net
benefit or the net negative of this
actually end up which side of the scale
it ends up falling out on like is it
is the sedation
uh is the fact that you're no longer
motivated to go out and do do something
meet people in the real world yourself
is the titrated dose of real world
connection worth that and then you know
Downstream let's say that it is or it
isn't it doesn't really matter if that's
what people are going to do
you are 100 going to face some genuine
externalities like population collabs
and and that's just
regardless of whether it's better for
people or Worse until you've got ivg and
wombs artificial wombs you're you're
[__] on that front so real real
inflection point of change I think at
the moment enormous you know absolutely
enormous and proliferating in ways that
that we don't anticipate either
um
and yeah I think it's really important
to not get too Doom and Gloom about it
because you know you're absolutely right
um you know
that cherry turkle says you know robots
may be better than nothing but they're
not enough and I would say in response
to that
um they're better than nothing and
that's all that some people have you
know because there is so much loneliness
out there
um and you know I I think that the
replica AI
um romance spot that um you know
recently they they sort of shut off
their erotic role plays because they had
a licensing issue Etc and you know
people were bereft they really this for
them this was a very real relationship
they know it's not a real relationship
but but it feels real and it pushes real
buttons for them and that's the only way
that those buttons get pushed and I
think that you know the potential for
this stuff to make us feel more human is
enormous
um and and so you know all of that good
shouldn't be thrown out with with all of
the bad that's out there
um and you know we we're we will have to
navigate it very carefully and very
delicately
um and hopefully with with with an
openness that isn't simply ideological
knee-jerk reactions
it's hard man it's harder you hear about
these stories you hear about these
things happening and you just default to
right Luddite it switch it off pull the
plug we're not going to have this or
there's a massive amount of
um like
conceptual inertia or or naturalistic
um fallacy that this there's an ick
around you know you hear about Dave cat
and you think this guy's doing what with
this robot and it's you know you think
that's but then you know on the flip
side there's all manner of relationships
that people used to think were
reprehensible and sometimes illegal and
sometimes resulted in castration that
have been perfectly accepted and um
yeah it's it's a really really tough one
man when we've got cuddle cafes you know
and men that pay women not to have sex
with them but just to sit and be with
them or vice versa women you know
increasing amounts of polygyny because
you've got a scarcity of of men that
perhaps some women are looking for
you've got increases in domestic
violence and
um like benefit inflicting mating
behavior from men because women who
didn't date hypergamously are
threatening their that they know that
they don't need them they're concerned
that they're going to leave them
you know when you change when you start
to change the Dynamics that the mating
Market has sort of vestigially had for a
long time you end up with some really
strange externalities and I think that
we're just permanently eating all of
those and then technology speeding them
up uh and you know the the other thing
the most common element that everybody
is familiar with when it comes to mating
is the matchmaking stuff and the
matchmaking stuff doesn't seem to have
got particularly much better either you
know in some in some ways it's
facilitated an awful lot of
relationships I think between sort of 50
and 60 of relationships now begin online
in one form or another and um
even that like they're the most fragile
relationships they're also the ones that
on route to getting them could probably
cause a lot of externalities that people
aren't happy with
ghosting uh being swindled sort of yeah
it's a
it's gonna be an interesting for you
guys look Rob let's bring this one home
mate I really appreciate you I think
your work is fantastic uh where should
people go if they want to check out more
of the stuff that you do and keep up to
date with your work
keep up with my um with my writing at
Rob Brooks so Ro b b r double o k s dot
net
um and on Twitter it's Brooks underscore
Rob um and you should be able to to give
most of what I say perfect Rob I
appreciate you thank you if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe